They should be designing for the places and the people, the landscapes
that the wall endangers.
Now, people are already rising to this occasion,
and while the purpose of the wall is to keep people apart and away,
it's actually bringing people together in some really remarkable ways,
holding social events like binational yoga classes along the border,
to bring people together across the divide.
I call this the monument pose.
(Laughter)
And have you ever heard of "wall y ball"?
It's a borderland version of volleyball, and it's been played since 1979
(Laughter)
along the US-Mexico border
to celebrate binational heritage.
And it raises some interesting questions, right?
Is such a game even legal?
Does hitting a ball back and forth over the wall constitute illegal trade?
(Laughter)
The beauty of volleyball is that it transforms the wall
into nothing more than a line in the sand
negotiated by the minds and bodies and spirits of players on both sides.
And I think it's exactly these kinds of two-sided negotiations
that are needed to bring down walls that divide.
Now, throwing the ball over the wall is one thing,
but throwing rocks over the wall
has caused damage to Border Patrol vehicles
and have injured Border Patrol agents,
and the response from the US side has been drastic.
Border Patrol agents have fired through the wall,
killing people throwing rocks on the Mexican side.
And another response by Border Patrol agents
is to erect baseball backstops to protect themselves and their vehicles.
And these backstops became a permanent feature
in the construction of new walls.
And I began to wonder if, like volleyball,
maybe baseball should be a permanent feature at the border,
and walls could start opening up,
allowing communities to come across and play,
and if they hit a home run,
maybe a Border Patrol agent would pick up the ball and throw it
back over to the other side.
A Border Patrol agent buys a raspado, a frozen treat,
from a vendor just a couple feet away,
food and money is exchanged through the wall,
an entirely normal event made illegal by that line drawn on a map
and a couple millimeters of steel.
And this scene reminded me of a saying:
"If you have more than you need, you should build longer tables
and not higher walls."
So I created this souvenir to remember the moment that we could share
food and conversation across the divide.
A swing allows one to enter and swing over to the other side
until gravity deports them back to their own country.
The border and the border wall
is thought of as a sort of political theater today,
so perhaps we should invite audiences to that theater,
to a binational theater where people can come together
with performers, musicians.
Maybe the wall is nothing more than an enormous instrument,
the world's largest xylophone, and we could play down this wall
with weapons of mass percussion.
(Laughter)
When I envisioned this binational library,
I wanted to imagine a space where one could share
books and information and knowledge across a divide,
where the wall was nothing more than a bookshelf.
And perhaps the best way to illustrate the mutual relationship that we have
with Mexico and the United States
is by imagining a teeter-totter,
where the actions on one side had a direct consequence
on what happens on the other side,
because you see, the border itself
is both a symbolic and literal fulcrum for US-Mexico relations,
and building walls between neighbors severs those relationships.
You probably remember this quote, "Good fences make good neighbors."
It's often thought of as the moral of Robert Frost's poem "Mending Wall."
But the poem is really about questioning the need for building walls at all.
It's really a poem about mending human relationships.
My favorite line is the first one:
"Something there is that doesn't love a wall."
Because if there's one thing that's clear to me --
there are not two sides defined by a wall.
This is one landscape, divided.
On one side, it might look like this.
A man is mowing his lawn while the wall is looming in his backyard.
And on the other side, it might look like this.
The wall is the fourth wall of someone's house.
But the reality is that the wall is cutting through people's lives.
It is cutting through our private property,
our public lands,
our Native American lands, our cities,
a university,
our neighborhoods.
And I couldn't help but wonder
what it would be like if the wall cut through a house.
Remember those disparities between wealth and poverty?
On the right is the average size of a house in El Paso, Texas,
and on the left is the average size of a house in Juarez.
And here, the wall cuts directly through the kitchen table.
And here, the wall cuts through the bed in the bedroom.
Because I wanted to communicate how the wall is not only dividing places,
it's dividing people, it's dividing families.
And the unfortunate politics of the wall
is today, it is dividing children from their parents.
You might be familiar with this well-known traffic sign.
It was designed by graphic designer John Hood,
a Native American war veteran
working for the California Department of Transportation.
And he was tasked with creating a sign to warn motorists
of immigrants who were stranded alongside the highway
and who might attempt to run across the road.
Hood related the plight of the immigrant today
to that of the Navajo during the Long Walk.
And this is really a brilliant piece of design activism.
And he was very careful
in thinking about using a little girl with pigtails, for example,
because he thought that's who motorists might empathize with the most,
and he used the silhouette of the civil rights leader Cesar Chavez
to create the head of the father.
I wanted to build upon the brilliance of this sign
to call attention to the problem of child separation at the border,
and I made one very simple move.
I turned the families to face each other.
And in the last few weeks,
I've had the opportunity to bring that sign back to the highway
to tell a story,
the story of the relationships that we should be mending
and a reminder that we should be designing
a reunited states and not a divided states.
Thank you.
(Applause)